Similar to ADHD, ASD is thought to be caused by a combination of genetics and
environment. Some genes may make a child more susceptible to the disorder.
Others may determine the severity of the symptoms. Some of the genetic problem
seems to be inherited. Whereas others happen spontaneously. Environmental
factors also play a role. And researchers are examining whether viral
infections, complications during pregnancy, or even air pollutants can play a
role in triggering autism. What is not a cause of ASD? While there is no
evidence or reliable research that has shown a link between vaccines and ASD.
That is, there is no scientific data to support such claims. Now the reason I'm
telling you there's no link between vaccines and ASD is because some people
actually think there is a link. And one of the reasons was because of
fraudulent data that was presented by Doctor Andrew Wakefield. In his previous
research, he was found to be fraudulent because he misrepresented or altered
the medical records of the 12 patients he used for his now infamous study.
Doctor Wakefield's misconduct was so inexcusable that Britain stripped him of
his medical license. Neglecting the recommended vaccines exposes children to
the danger of catching and spreading serious diseases like measles, mumps or
whooping cough. So vaccination is key to eliminating these serious diseases.
And we know now that vaccines do not cause ASD. So vaccinate. Now, let's go to
Lauren to talk about the anxiety disorders.